etonnant non c'est une émission de
radiophonie ça s'appelle les chroniques
de la haine ordinaire le plus sourd
d'entre vous chers auditeurs aura
entendu parler des demoiselles monaco à
moins que vous ne lisiez que des
journaux intelligent vous n'avez pas pu
échapper à leur effigie de laitières peu
de clés qui s'étale périodiquement à la
une des organes populacier savez le
poids des mots le choc des lolos voyez
ce que je veux dire
rien ne m'autorise à porter le moindre
jugement esthétique ou morale sur le
bien fondé des exhibitions répétitif de
ces cocottes d'azur dont les images
rassurantes vienne forte à propos nous
faire oublier les femmes squelette au
sein vide
accroupis sur les plages de sable
infinie de nos lointains sahel je ne me
permettrais pas davantage de ricaner
prétentieusement d'un lapsus n'a guère
échapper des lèvres aux aubergines de la
cadette
c'est la bêtise et stéphanie c'était au
cours de l'émission scoop à la une
produite par catherine barma le 27
octobre dernier sur tf1
il était 16h42 non je donne d'entrée de
jeu c'est fastidieuse précision
bureaucratique à l'intention de l'avocat
des grimaldi spécialisés
qu'il est spécialisé dans les procédures
diffamatoires afin de lui épargner une
action en justice perdu d'avancé
on n'entend pas le bras d'honneur quand
je pose en fait on débattait donc sur ce
plateau des avantages et des
inconvénients de la tauromachie
lorsque mademoiselle monaco c'est fanny
donc eu cette saillie si j'ose dire si
j'ose dire s'agissant de ces fiers
bestiaux dans la haute tenue copulatoire
n'est plus à vanter chez les bobines en
rut deux points ouvrons donc les
guillemets avec révérence c'est la
princesse qui cause je suis contre la
tauromachie
après tout les taureaux ne sont ils pas
des êtres humains comme les autres
je le répète il ne peut s'agir en
l'occurrence que d'un lapsus un lapsus
bien pardonnable et non pas de
l'expression involontaire d'une tendance
à la zoophilie
nous ne devons pas perdre de vue avant
de nous lancer dans de malveillantes
insinuations totalement injustifié que
les produits destinés à faire vendre du
papier comme lotus où les princesses
monégasques sont soumises à toutes
sortes de pressions avant d'être livrée
au public
d'où une certaine fatigue bien excusable
après tout les roitelets d'opérette ne
sont ils pas des êtres humains comme les
autres
mais alors direz vous et vous n'auriez
pas tort pourquoi cet imbécile nous
bourrer souffle-t-il le cortex avec 6
ragoût méridionaux et bien simplement
parce que j'ai été profondément heurté
dans ma fierté républicaine d'entendre
et de voir l'autre jour un animateur de
jeu français dont je tairai le nom pour
ne pas faire de publicité à patrice
laffont
ce pilier jusqu'à se lécher les genoux
devant la donzelle susnommé et lui dire
je cite c'est un grand honneur pour nous
de vous avoir parmi nous ce soir votre
altesse sérénissime
alors là je dis non était ce vraiment la
peine de guillotiné le gros cap et de se
battre pour les congés payés de donner
le droit de vote aux épices hier et
maintenant de supporter la gueule à
krasucki tout ça pour en arriver là
allons patrice patrice mon pote secoue
toi on a quand même pas pris la bastille
que pour en faire un opéra simeray prêts
publics à primo ce n'est pas un grand
honneur pour toi patrice que de recevoir
stéphanie de monaco à la finale des
chiffres et des lettres
c'est un grand honneur pour elle que
d'avoir le droit de s'exhiber multimédia
alors qu'elle n'a rien d'autre à faire
que de montrer son blaser son blason à
tous les passants deuxio on n'appelle
pas n'importe qui altesse sérénissime de
la hauteur et de la sérénité
il y en a chez l'abbé pierre chez chez
les basanés qui marche contre les cons
grand teint il y en a chez joëlle
kauffmann qui a pas tellement le temps
de pleurer
il y en a chez les toubibs aux 80 des
tortures et des morts de la hauteur et
de la sérénité
il y en a un chez mère teresa et même
chez le militant transit qui croient
dans l'humanité le dimanche l'altesse et
la sérénité
la majesté en un mot ça n'est pas
héréditaire mon camarade ça ne s'attrape
pas au lit comme la vérole où le droit
d'aînesse la majesté ça vient du coeur
des gens c'est une élégance qu'on achète
page pierre cardin
[Applaudissements]
quant au mois de mars je le dis sans
aucune arrière pensée politique
ça m'étonnerait qu'ils passent l'hiver
[Applaudissements]
non non
[Musique]